si c'est la queue blanche comme neige que tu
cherches découvre l'histoire qui a
précédé le miroir sur le mur qui est la
plus belle d'entre elles tu es ma reine mais pas
pour longtemps
ta sœur est un bébé qui
deviendra plus belle que toi  mais attention
s'il devait arriver quelque mal à l'enfant
ta soeur Felicia ne ressemblait à rien pour
échapper à la douleur de sa perte la bonne
reine construisit une forteresse de glace autour de son
coeur si elle ne pouvait pas élever un enfant elle
lèverait une armée tu as été formé il
était devenu  mon chasseur,
bien sûr, je pensais que je t'avais rendu fort mais le
tien est pathétique comme tu l'as jamais été c'est
mon royaume as-tu dit quelque chose avec
la magie de Mary je vais gouverner ce
qui compte une chose mauvaise et dangereuse
nous devons détruire
qu'est-ce que tu vas faire être le  héros qui
vainc le
miroir tout le royaume je prie beaucoup
êtes-vous prêt hon Smith
je suis plus fort que vous tous allons-nous
découvrir l'histoire avant que la neige ne te blanchisse